salut c'est monsieur gros comme toutes
les personnes qui font de la vidéo j'ai
des gros problèmes de stockage de
données tout simplement parce que la
vidéo prend beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de places en les disques durs et un
moment bon il faut savoir un peu au la
stocker donc quand on m'a proposé de
tester un as je me suis dit ok why not
mais c'est quoi un aspect est pas
d'expert là dedans
d'ailleurs je suis toujours pas parce
que moi jusqu'à présent quand je
sauvegarde et j'avais ce matos là et ce
matos là autant vous dire que y'en a
plein d'entre vous qui vont se marrer
stocker toute ta vidéo là dedans c'est
bien mais c'est un peu léger et synology
m'a proposé une solution intéressante
qui se situe quant aux cartes on l'a
donc on va faire une vidéo où on va
regarder le ds210 8 plus de synology on
va l'ouvrir on va regarder s'il est bien
andré tester et au final je vous dirai
si je suis très adopté cette solution
est passé de mon petit stockage format
mini piper optimisée à ça on y va
voici le monstre on va essayer de
l'ouvrir voir un petit peu comment ces
fichus à l'intérieur c'est là bas que je
fasse de la porte au toit à la la qu'est
quelque chose près comment ça souffle
tout vu
alors qu'avant nous ici diskstation ds
218 plus de b
synology high performance holloway
accessible nas serveur autre chose on va
regarder ce cas là dedans et yoann wolfe
douce terra donc j'en ai un
j'en étais ici diskstation
qu'avons nous à nice avec beaucoup de
précautions dans une espèce de petite
chaussette
alors qu'on nous synology a de la gueule
ça a vraiment de la gueule
alors comment ça fonctionne la l'arrière
agit de la connectique usb usb lan
alimentation esata un bouton pour
l'allumer ce kit mes infos de réseaux
disque à disque de hockey là je viens à
serrer mes disques directement ici
génial top
bon alors si je comprends bien comment
ça marche ici je dois mettre mon disque
dur au monde disque glisse à l'intérieur
normalement je dois pas être trop trop
mal je suis en face je clique d'un côté
de l'autre et je pense que je vais dans
le rack deuxième et je lui mets dans le
rack et là il est connecté à facebook ou
plus lourd donc là j'ai deux disques
durs de 12 ferrat directement dans mon
rac
maintenant il me reste plus qu'à le
brancher je dois avoir des câbles prise
ethernet pour connecter au réseau est là
et m'a prise là ouf voilà donc y'a plus
qu'à essayer et une fois que j'ai tout
mis dans mon sac là je remets mon petit
capot sur le dehors c'est tout beau tout
joli tout mignon par contre ici j'ai pas
de prise ethernet donc on va changer de
crémerie changement de crèmerie alors je
me suis positionné dans un autre bureau
j'ai ici mon synology qui est branché
directement sur une prise
électrique tranquillement et l'autre
côté la prise ethernet pour le brancher
à mon réseau
ça fonctionne plutôt pas mal alors je
dois reconnaître que sur le bureau ça
prend pas trop de place à côté de mon
ordi ça va c'est pas mal maintenant
point un tout petit peu négatif de cette
bête c'est qu'elle fait quand même un
peu de bruit on entend un petit souffle
c'est assez léger par contre dès que je
me connectais dessus tout de suite ça va
ronfler un petit peu plus à côté de ça
ce truc est vraiment super parce que on
configure très très très facilement la
prise en main est super simple et d'un
point de vue logiciel c'est top je vous
montrais jeux connectés directement à
mon serveur en local en wifi donc je
peut stocker ou je veux j'ai accès à
tout ce qui est super bien c'est que la
jeanne espèce de centre de pâques et cd
comme des applications qui sont
préinstallés y en a qui sont
préinstallés à lac-etchemin installé ce
faire pas mal de choses avec donc moi ce
que j'ai déjà installées dans la machine
mais c'est toute la gestion de l'audio
audio stephen que je pense retrouver sur
mon portable à la gestion de mes
fichiers
j'ai un ph p 7 bon ok des moments c'est
pour retrouver un peu vos photos et vos
éléments en fonction des moments photo
stephen pareil pour gérer vos photos
distance gérer la vidéo de la sauvegarde
avec le biker usb copies bon à l'aprilia
de trucs ne sait pas encore exactement
comme ça parce que je ne suis pas un
professionnel du tout ça et ensuite vous
avez toutes les choses que vous pouvez
installer
donc ça c'est super parce que faire des
sauvegardes pour office microsoft office
vous installer un antivirus la gestion
de calendriers partagés la gestion du
cloud en tchat
il ya pas mal de trucs que vous pouvez
installer et ça s'est vraiment bien
coupé rien de ce qu au forum du php
bb je crois j'ai vu des choses comme ça
mais vous pouvez installer le stephen
barry ya pas mal de trucs du double à du
groupe bal
donc si vous voulez vous faire un
serveur web vous pouvez aussi le faire
alors après ces passes en termes de
puissance et sera largement suffisant
mais par contre ce qui est génial c'est
pour quelqu'un comme moi ce qui est
vraiment bien c'est la gestion de l'eau
photos de vos vidéos distance pour vous
connecter c'est super après vous avez un
petit panneau de configuration ici vous
pouvez gérer vos utilisateurs vous gros
accès externes votre pipe connect pour
vous connecter de votre portable vous
soyez toute la gestion de fichiers
d'ailleurs enfin c'est vraiment une
interface qui est très très simple là
j'ai une application sur mon portable
qui s'appelle ds photo qui me permet de
retrouver mes albums avec toutes mes
photos à distance donc là j'ai mis
quelques photos du crs et ce qui est
génial c'est que à distance
collectés soit sur wii fit en local ou
sinon directement partout dans le monde
en 4g ou en wifi n'importe où dans le
monde
jacques c à toute ma banque d'imagés
accès aussi à toutes mes vidéos tout ce
dont j'ai besoin
je peux récupérer directement et importé
de mon à ce qui est positionné dans mon
bureau que dans mon téléphone est pareil
pour mon ordinateur tous les fichiers
que j'ai dans mon as quel que soit
l'endroit où choix dans le monde
ce peut être par exemple aoc usa dégâts
ça peut être n'importe où je peux tout
récupéré dans mon asthme le cran demande
à des cannes dès lors j'ai une bonne
connexion internet ce qui tout récupérer
et ça c'est vraiment génial
alors au final que penser de ce nas
parce que c'est vrai qu'à la base je
connaissais absolument rien qui s'était
posé la question de stockage à me dire
bon il va me falloir un disque dur
encore externe
encore un autre encore un autre mais
l'idée d'avoir une machine comme
celle-là sur laquelle je peux me
connecter n'importe où dans le monde
pour avoir accès à mes données après
c'est pareil tu peux même faire de la
surveillance par exemple pour mon studio
je peux poser une caméra par ip avoir ça
dans un local technique de pouvoir
surveiller mon studio de pouvoir
enregistrer si jamais il ya des moments
et ça s'est vraiment bien donc au final
une petite boîte comme ça coûte pas très
cher avec deux disques qui me permet
d'avoir un double au niveau de mes
sauvegardes
c'est vraiment super bravo synology
merci leur a permis de découvrir le
système nas ça c'est plutôt bien et
c'est plutôt satisfait et je pense que
c'est un projet sur lequel je prends une
positionner bon et vous vous en pensez
quoi est-ce que vous avez déjà du nas ou
sauvegarde pour être gestion pour un
vote la chine est ce que ça pourrait
vous intéresser et si oui si vous
l'utilisez ce qui m'intéresse c'est
vraiment de me dire quelle utilisation
vous en avez j'imagine la sauvegarde
parce que c'est probablement
l'utilisation menace parce qu'ils ont
utilisé en tant que serveur utilisé pour
une star d'un oued être utilisé pour une
servante je dois énormément de
possibilités
marquis matou sans commentaire je suis
vraiment curieux qui peut permettre
aussi world - de nouveaux horizons par
rapport à ma création par rapport à tout
le travail car qu'est-ce que je fais
sont étudiants vous marquez tout son
commentaire
on se retrouve très bientôt marquer à
tous vos avis question interrogations
suggestions directement tout en bas
merci à vous d'être toujours plus
nombreux toujours plus nombreuses
de très très bientôt des grands bisous
soyez sages
[Musique]